and now it's time for time for a special
black history month edition of is it
racist that's where I show you a racist
clip and you decide if it's racist this
segment has never been more important
[Applause]
[Music]
calm down calm down
there's nothing racist about someone
enjoying fruit however when someone's
eating it that aggressively you might
not want a bunch of old white women
cheering her on like they've got money
ride donors so yes I believe that was a
tad racist and I know how she feels I
was recently in an eating contest and
I'm confident my race gave me a
competitive advantage
[Music]
[Applause]
done
[Music]
[Applause]
the trick to winning that contest you
got a dip in water before you and that's
how you play is it racist
you